how you doing hi
welcome welcome yeah so i wanted to pull
you in because
uh where was your super chat here
because you were talking about
basically entering the frame of a dude i
um i was gonna say i first um yeah
okay so married three years it's
important for wives to accept that
they'll do 95
so like why do you subscribe to this
notion like why
are you different from the majority of
women out there today that are like
you know i don't need no man and i can
do anything a man can do
and all that sort of stuff well i was
first gonna say about the chores
um i just think it's kind of like
it's easier to just do it yourself
and clean it the way you want than like
bothering
your husband like oh when are you going
to run the dishwasher when are you going
to do it and just like it's easier just
to do it yourself
then to like nag and then like the other
thing is
um like in my situation
i definitely do not earn most of the
money i earn like
a fraction of it so i just figure like
if he's working hard and like giving us
this nice
lifestyle that we have then are you
staying home mom for the most part or
what are you stay-at-home mom for the
most part no um
no i work full-time i just had my first
baby
and i'm on maternity leave now but uh
um i'm gonna go back part-time like in
may
um but um i think that a lot of people
or women like say that they don't want a
mana they don't need a man but i think
that they are
um i don't know
not like wrong they're like they have
the completely incorrect mindset and
there's like
so much joy to be had if like in a happy
marriage
did you guys have this conversation
before you got married and had kids
about gender roles like i'm gonna go out
and
you know uh catch the bacon i'll bring
it home and you cook it up
no i think it was just like or is it
just understood
no when we were dating um he
knew how much or how little i was making
and
he was okay with that like he was okay
with the fact that like
i was only earning like a certain amount
so he knew
that i would not contribute that much
financially so like i guess if he didn't
like the fact that
i wasn't making that much then he
wouldn't
have proposed i would say what advice
would you give to me
he was okay with the fact that i not
like
yes i live in new york city but i'm not
so so what advice would you give to men
so that they don't have to put up with
these insufferable
you know women with the boss girl
attitudes and all those you know i don't
need no man stuff
because i mean like most of the guys
watching my channel right now are going
to be men there's a few women it's like
you know one in ten are women
you know that like to be a fly in the
wall and sometimes they'll contribute
you know kind of like you have but
i thought you were gonna say like what's
your advice to women um
um let's deal with the advice you know
to men first and then let's deal with
the advice to women
so what's the advice for like um
guys who are dealing with like like the
alpha types
well a lot of guys want to have kids you
know you need a
you need a decent woman for that it's
very it's very high risk
and low reward for men i mean i wrote a
book
basically on all the risks that men need
to march through when it comes to
the sexual marketplace today so they so
they get it but they still ask the
question
okay so how do i have kids if i want to
have kids you know what if i want to
have company what if i want to have a
woman in my life right
i would say like a lot of times like
women will say like oh i want
kids um one day like like when you're
dating they're like you might hear the
baby in the background but oh
yeah okay um
um i would say like a lot of times when
men are dating
they're like the woman will say like oh
i want kids like one day i think it's
like best if they kind of like
nail down like well how soon is that
gonna be because
the truth is like when you get to your
30s it takes
longer to conceive so like if you're
like dating a girl who's like little 20
she's like oh one day well that's fine
because that'll probably be like in like
a few years but if a guy wants kids like
find a woman who will be like you know
what like once we're married let's like
start trying
because it always takes longer or it
really does how old are you now oh i
am 31 but i'll be 32 next one okay
and this is your first child yeah thank
god she's healthy and
she's a month old and i'm very proud
congratulations so um what advice would
you give to women then
you know like do you think this whole
boss girl narrative like do you think
that the three girls one kitchen
narrative about doing puzzles and
watching some documentaries is the way
to find a high value guy
i think that like you know like i'm in
accounting and i like accounting
um but i think there's so much more
joy and pride that you feel
like in the pregnancy and like once you
have the child
that like that joy and pride like look
what i did and
what my body did and like all this stuff
that you that you get with a baby than
you will ever have with
um a job or a career like you
like i am good at accounting and i've
been in accounting since i graduated
college
um but there's like really no
comparison like the pride i feel when i
push the stroller
or like take selfies with the baby or
like
when people compliment me there's no
comparison
a lot of women like oh my career my
career
but it's just that level of joy is
you can't compare it um how do you deal
with the
parent like the uh parenting
responsibility like let's say in the
middle of the night
uh you know your daughter's crying you
know what children do in the middle of
night
obviously do you get up to deal with it
does he deal with it do you take turns
i deal with it well i'm on maternity
leave so
um
yeah i mean like um i think that
baby's crying do you need to deal with
that or is your husband i don't see him
like
succeeding and oh i mean i'm sure he can
give a bottle but like i don't know
okay um your daughter's crying do you
need to deal with that is your husband
no rob is giving her a bag okay fair
enough good good
doesn't sound like she's enjoying that
beth
all right um okay so before i let you go
is there anything else that you want to
leave
um for people i would say i wasn't
always in this mindset i think the way i
got to it is i've read a lot of um
anti books like anti-feminist books
and also like anti-feminist podcasts
like
were you ever feminist like did you ever
subscribe to i don't need no man and
let's climb the corporate ladder
when i was in my low 20s like all my
friends started having like
serious boyfriends and like getting
engaged and i was like well when is it
gonna be my turn
so um i don't think i was ever
like drunk on that feminism stuff
luckily i didn't get sucked into it what
do you think that is
because culture upbringing religion what
your friends are doing like
if your friends are all having like
serious boyfriends and getting engaged
then you want that
but like it does like your siblings can
be doing whatever
but it's like what your friends are
doing so if all your friends are like
i mean i get like the college hookup
thing like everyone does that
that's like typical but it's like
it's like what are your friends doing
their low 20s if they're getting serious
boyfriends and looking to get engaged
then you're just
doing that so okay all right i think it
really depends like what your friends
are doing honestly
cool well i appreciate you hopping on
and sharing some of your insights like
watching your channel and i also like
gum rule zero and thank you for
everything
you got it thanks for hopping on i
appreciate your super chats yeah you too
have a good night see ya
ciao all right um oh i forgot to ask her
this question i saw the super chat pop
up um i'm i'm sure that she would agree
that it's here actually she's still
there
um question does marissa think risk uh
marriage is too risky for men
um
if you're marrying like an alpha female
probably is risky
what's an alpha female um oh i have to
go um
just someone who's like trying to like
delay uh um just someone who's like
trying to do 50 50 with the chores or
like
everything well and like that that's
what i mean
got it okay so i'll let you go because i
know you got to go down bye
okay so um yeah it's like that is the
vast majority of of of women out there
today so when she's defining alpha
female it's
it's not necessarily um you know like
the female version of an alpha male
that's how
women typically mess up that definition
uh we've talked about that before on
rule zero on my channel so i'm not going
to cover that but you get the point
you